there's a holy heck of a mess that
appears to be developing in Tampa
Florida involved in Florida involving
Jameis Winston in an account from an
uber driver that occurred back in March
of 2016 this super driver she alleged
that Jameis Winston groped her in a
drive-through of a Mexican restaurant in
Scottsdale Arizona he was coming off of
his rookie season with the bucks he
denied the allegation that became public
through a BuzzFeed report in 2017 she
said that she and Jameis were the only
passing of only people in the car he
sexually assaulted me and I have every
right to tell the damn truth about it
she told BuzzFeed Ronald Darby who now
plays for the Philadelphia Eagles who
was a teammate of Jameis Winston's in
college said at the time publicly that
the account was wrong because not only
was in Jameis in the front seat of the
car he was in the back seat but he was
in the back seat with him Ronald Darby
at the time said there there were three
of us in the car not just one as has
been reported myself and Jameis were in
the back seat I'm confident that nothing
inappropriate in nature happened in the
car that evening and Jameis did not have
any physical contact with the uber
driver the accusations are just not true
and when this came out in BuzzFeed in
November of 2017 that's when the league
started investigating which is why there
were some reports yesterday that the
three-game suspension that's being
handed down to Jameis Winston not
officially yet but that's expected to
come down on Jameis Winston was because
he didn't report the incident right away
as is required by the collective
bargaining agreement to help us make
heads or tails of all this Bucs beat
writer and columnist for the Tampa Bay
Times Rich Stroud how are you rekt I'm
doing well rich I'm doing good and let
me just I'll start where you ended there
as far as not reporting I mean at the
time that this occurred at the end of
his rookie season there was no such
stipulation that players had to report
that that came later in December and I
can tell you with confidence that that
is not a factor in this case at all they
spent eight months investigating this
case they interviewed a ton of witnesses
yeah there is a he said
she said element to it we've seen on NFL
Network they reported that you know the
Darby wasn't in the car the entire time
apparently
we still don't know who the alleged
third passenger was because Winston and
no one will tell anyone
so there's a lot of conflicting things
but as far as this notion and I think it
was put out you know by Tallahassee
radio show host and it's just it feels
like so much spin but my information or
my reporting is that that is not why
he's getting three games and it's for
violating the the player conduct penalty
code because it's very broad and let's
face it we know what Jameis came into
the league with and now he's had two of
these allegations and so you know he's
going to get a minimum of three games
and possibly more if he doesn't you know
do what the NFL is going to require him
to do that will likely be undisclosed
yeah and I want to say that again just
now that I was giving all the details
that he wasn't charged at with with
anything and he wasn't convicted
obviously of anything if it wasn't
charged the only thing that did happen
to him is that uber suspended his
account he needed to find a different
way to get rides around town wherever
town he was in Rick but that also
doesn't mean that the league can't
suspend him under its policy when it is
all said and done how is this sitting
with Tampa management Rick well they're
disappointed I mean this is the thing
that do you fear right I mean it's the
old saying you know you can lay down on
hey you may get eight hours sleep but
you're going to wake up scratching well
they woke up scratching today and you
know they interviewed 70 people you know
before they drafted them it was a
polarizing pick and the other choice
between him and Marcus Mariota the irony
is is that Lovie Smith was the guy at
the time that was so on board with
Jameis via course got fired after his
second year
Dirk cutter said openly he had taken
Marcus Mariota because he was friends
with Mark Halperin and just knew more
about him now Dirk is a very much a
Jameis guy now and this is going to fall
squarely on him and Jason Lyons who have
already on the hot seat after a you know
five win season now Jameis is going to
miss the first three games and minimum
you know those are huge games at New
Orleans home against a Super Bowl
champion Eagles home
the Monday night game against Pittsburgh
then they go to Chicago presumably he
could play then then there's a bye week
and four of his first five games would
be on the road so this is not going to
help their season it's a it's just it's
pretty much what they fear RIT's drought
Tampa Bay Times here on the Rich Eisen
show so how does this play out you say
it could be more and we have it I mean
it's come out that that the suspensions
come in we don't know how much or when
it's official what can you tell us Rick
well I think I mean it could be as early
as today it couldn't drag on to the next
week is what we know and look these
things are not done in a vacuum there's
a lot of conversation between the league
obviously and james's representatives
the information that we have and Adam
Schefter I think has reported this too
that they're there probably won't be an
appeal although that's still a
possibility and I think the reason why
they won't is that he wants to move
forward he wants to put this behind him
you know it's not that he's accepting
you know the version that was was put
out there by the uber driver and you
mentioned there was never criminal
charge so far a civil suit although I
would anticipate there be one later but
I think you know I are as the more part
goes like I said when the NFL does send
the letter and does make this official
they may not be enumerated but I think
there will be things that want him to
accomplish you know as far as whether
that's counseling or whatnot you know as
safeguards and and certainly if he were
to do you know if there any more of
these incidents come forward they could
they could add games but right now it
looks like a you know a minimum of three
games and you know we'll see we'll see
what happens when when the league
finally gets around to announcing the
suspension and the teams already picked
up his his fifth year player option 420
million and change
but that's only guaranteed with injury
is it entirely possible that we see how
the season plays out and the Bucs move
on as opposed to putting 20 million
dollars in the hands of somebody who
with this incident has proven to be
untrustworthy yeah I think it's
reasonable to say that that he
playing for his career in Tampa and that
you know he'll have a chance to come
back I mean everything is still in front
of him you know all outward appearances
since his rookie year he's done the
right things he's gonna have a his first
child in July he's getting married
he started a foundation he spends a lot
of time the community is so much good
about Jameis but I think I think that
you know he's gonna have to win I mean
this is a guy it's only 118 games in
three years there's my board overall
pick and you know you went to a horrible
football team but at some point the
winning has to happen as far as the 20
million you're right it's a guaranteed
only against injury if he's healthy and
passes of physical and March they can
decide not to give him that contract so
let's let's spin it forward and say okay
they don't have a great year and maybe
he plays okay maybe he doesn't but Dirk
cutter and Jason like gets fired now
you're looking at a situation where a
new head coach is coming in here
evaluating things top to bottom do they
really want to have one more year of
Jameis Winston I mean so there's a lot
at stake for him in Tampa right now and
for his career I mean he has put himself
in a position that he told the league he
would avoid he went to the NFL two weeks
before the start of the draft and you
know who requested a meeting with Roger
Goodell spent five hours in the NFL
office as I would imagine telling them
that you won't have a problem with me
and then and then this has happened so
he's playing for his career in Tampa and
maybe in the NFL the last one before you
hear Rick because you know I'm sure some
of fans listening to us or watching us
right now
heard what you said a couple of
questions ago and I just want to touch
upon it again from what you just said I
guess over the last several minutes if
he is you know turning his life around
the fact he's getting married having a
kid he's gonna be a dad he's got a
foundation and you're being suspended
for grabbing a woman's crotch well
wouldn't you fight that instead of
saying I want to turn the page I mean
this is millions on the line Rick yeah
it's reasonable to think that but
there's a couple things one we've seen
where these appeals go right nobody wins
them and they will don't win them
because they usually boil down to does
the NFL have the right to investigate
to make a decision and punishing the
answer is yes they gave that away in the
CVA okay so you could fight it
but when you do what happens now the
NFL's investigative report which at this
point is not being shared by anybody
except to Jameis and his representatives
that all becomes public now because now
the NFL is going to try the merits of
the case and we'll hear things about due
process which we know doesn't really
exist nor does it have to so I think
from a PR standpoint it may not be what
Jameis wants out there we don't know
what you know culpability he has we
don't know what his story was maybe he
prefers it that way so there's a lot of
motivations and I'm sure it's a tough
call I'm sure people look at it as you
know maybe an admission of guilt which
is not necessarily but I think that you
know I think that he's got to make the
best decision for himself and for his
football team you know that's another
thing like what's the week-to-week drama
and the cost of idiot you know the stays
and the appeal and he's gonna play this
week is he not you know take his three
games move on try to have a great season
appreciate the time and the information
we'll chat soon Thanks right you guys
it's Rick Stroud Tampa Bay Times Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience